there are some huge changes coming to
overwatch too from new heroes and
mechanics to a whole new free-to-play
model we're gonna round up all the big
news as well as hear straight from the
game's director aaron keller about what
we can expect when overwatch 2 launches
on october 4th
obviously one of the biggest changes is
that overwatch 2 will be going free to
play when we asked aaron why the answer
was pretty simple it keeps the player
base together rather than releasing
another box that players would have to
buy in order to opt into the experience
we'd rather open the game to as a broad
of a population as possible so overwatch
is a game of teamwork and cooperation
and strategy and and we feel like it's
played best in a social setting or with
your friends and so removing that
barrier to entry
um the the at the price is a barrier to
entry is hopefully a way for you to be
able to play with more of your friends
and have a better experience with the
game
on top of that just like in overwatch
one there's cross platform play which
will be enabled in the game's second
beta which will be on xbox playstation
and pc at the end of june if you're
going to be playing overwatch 2 on a
different platform than you played
overwatch 1 have no fear there's cross
platform progression 2. details on how
that will work are thin on the ground
right now but as someone who has to have
a playstation overwatch account and a pc
one i can't wait to finally bring all my
unlocks together into one game over the
past couple of years overwatch has
definitely had a content problem yes
there's been timed events and regular
competitive seasons but the last new
hero was echo and she launched over two
years ago with overwatch 2 becoming free
to play the team are being more
transparent with players changing how
they approach releasing new content and
making sure there are enough frequent
updates to keep players coming back each
overwatch 2 season will last about 9
weeks and there'll be a new hero every
other season you heard that right the
drought is over each season will
apparently have more content than the
team has ever shipped seasonally before
so brace yourselves there'll be new
heroes maps game modes events features
and even systems in order to make it all
the overwatch team is now three times
the size it used to be let's delve into
that road map then season one kicks off
on october 4th and there'll be three new
heroes junker queen sojourn and a
mysterious third who is an unannounced
support hero there'll be six new maps we
saw four in the first beta and a new one
is coming in the next there'll be a
battle pass and by the way overwatch 2
will have a battle pass model and
there'll be 30 plus new skins a new game
mode and a new mythic skin but more on
that later
season 2 will launch on december 6th and
will include a new tank hero new math 30
plus new skins new battle pass and a new
mythic skin
leveling up in overwatch 2 won't net you
that sweet sweet loot box anymore when
we asked aaron why he had this to say
loot boxes they've always been a part of
overwatch one but as the game has grown
and especially as we go into a
free-to-play version of the game where
we're adding more and more cosmetics
it becomes a lot harder to earn what you
want with a loot box system and so um by
losing those and moving over to a shop
for overwatch 2 it gives players the
actual agency and the choice to go after
what it is they want to have in the game
you can earn certain unlockables through
the game's battle pass but you can also
buy things from the in-game shop in
addition to classic unlocks like skins
voice lines and sprays they'll also be
new items like weapon charms and mythic
skins which are basically a cut above a
legendary skin for one mythic skins are
customizable season one's mythic skin
will be genji and according to aaron you
can swap out his tattoos change their
colors and check out the visual effects
added to his mask there'll be a new
mythic skin with every season earlier
this year blizzard revealed that the pve
was being decoupled from the multiplayer
part of overwatch 2 and questions have
been swirling on how exactly the
campaign content will work well we
finally have an answer and know why that
model changed when we
initially announced overwatch 2
we presented a vision of a pvp
game that
had a big pve component to it at the
same time
and as we developed that game
what it meant was that the pvp side of
the game was coupled or was joined with
the pve side of the game and so the
release of any pvp content was now being
gated by the amount of time it took for
us to to build the pve side of the game
and as that took longer it meant that
there was less focus going in to the
live side of the game
and
this i feel like this went against one
of the core values that the overwatch
team has always had which is to be able
to deliver content regularly for our
players and so the longer that went i
think we realized that
we had to change something
and so i understand that that there was
a vision of what overwatch 2 was but we
are changing that and the reason that we
are changing that is because we want to
be able to get content to our players as
soon as we possibly can we think that
that is the right thing to do for our
community we think it's the right thing
to do for the game it's the right thing
to do for all of our players and so that
was the initial
impetus of what caused us to to
completely
change our strategy overwatch 2 is going
to have a full aaa campaign with a
linear story and a replayable mode
that'll include hero progression instead
of releasing those separately they'll
launch as part of overwatch 2's seasonal
cadence starting in 2023 the pve
differentiates massively from pvp
because progression is tied to each hero
as you level them up they can gain more
talent and equipment we've heard about a
few of these new abilities like tracer
being able to damage enemies by blinking
through them and reinhardt being able to
gain armor when his barrier breaks
they'll be talking more about pve closer
to its rollout the 34th hero coming to
overwatch is junker queen a new tank
hero who will be playable in the
upcoming june beta not only does she
look let's face it
amazing but she actually brings new
mechanics to overwatch i'll let aaron
break it down she utilizes a mechanic
called bleed
and when she does certain types of
damage to characters she receives
that same amount
as overhealth to her and there's lots of
different ways for her to do it and she
fights with an axe
a dagger and she uses this like
electromagnetic gauntlet to control some
of this so when she throws her dagger
out she can then reactivate the ability
and pull it back
and it will pull it will like
pierce everybody that's in the way of it
so you can hit somebody on the way out
and pull it back and do damage to them
again or sometimes you can purposefully
miss
and put it behind a team and then pull
it back through them
hitting each one of them applying a
bleed to each one of them and taking all
of that as overhealth
also when she swings her axe when she
cleaves with it
she can take all of that damage and
apply a bleed and get that as over
health as well so if she's playing right
and hitting people frequently she's able
to be really tanky and kind of just stay
up in front of people and on top of that
she has a buff where she shouts
and she gives basically a haste
as well as over health to to herself as
well as all of her allies and so she's
one of these tanks that um she might not
be she's not long range but when she's
in the thick of things and when she's
hitting people she's really really hard
to take down the overwatch team also
debuted a new map for pvp called paraiso
the map is set in rio which means lucio
fans will find a lot to love about it
especially because the last third of the
map actually takes place in lucio's club
and the defending team spawns in his
home one of my favorite things about
busan is that you get to see diva's
space so i'm really hoping lucio's home
is packed full of easter eggs in terms
of the map itself it's a hybrid one so
the attacking team will need to capture
a point and then escort a payload
through the rest of the map in terms of
what characters will excel on this map
it's all about mobility baby there's
high ground all around the first point
and each team has a different way to
access it so defense can kind of access
high ground from their side of the point
and offense has a few ways of accessing
it from their side and so there's um a
lot of use for highly mobile characters
on on this map and then as you move
through um and get towards the end um
the the high ground actually continues
um and so there's as you travel through
this um sort of like more quaint village
section of rio there's different
rooftops that you can get to there's
different levels of lucio's club that
you can get to um and i think that it's
like it's a really fun
map that really highlights a lot of our
heroes movement abilities um as well as
a lot of the um sort of like long range
sight lines that we have while still
providing all these like tight little
flanking routes for heroes like reaper
um and um
i was gonna say junker queen
and junker queen to excel on
paraiso will be playable in the june
beta but if that wasn't enough we also
caught a glimpse of another new map
called portugal i've got some sneaky
footage of it right here looks like it's
another push map to go with the new game
mode that we'll be debuting with
overwatch 2.
as a huge overwatch fan honestly the new
changes have me very excited
we have been kept starving of overwatch
content for the past couple of years and
the promise of at least the first year
and beyond already being mapped out with
new heroes and maps and modes is
incredibly incredibly exciting and it
makes me want to delve back in it
obviously remains to be seen how the
micro transactions will work now that we
don't have loot boxes anymore and if the
battle pass is going to be satisfying
every season but i guess we'll have to
wait and see to find out if you want to
see more from our interview with aaron
keller make sure to subscribe to the
channel we'll be posting it shortly and
for more on overwatch 2 make sure to
stay tuned to gamespot